if you've seen any of the Michael Bay
Transformers movies you are probably
confused after seeing bumblebee get
brutally murdered by Scourge in Rise of
the beasts you also probably saw his
final Act Resurrection coming a mile
away Optimus primal shows Optimus Prime
a bed of Rich latent inner John near the
human village where the maximals live
they rest bumblebee there but Primal
explains that since the inner John isn't
active it won't be enough to revive him
after Scourge uses the transwarp key to
open a portal Unicron begins to pass
through into Earth's atmosphere as he
does he blasts the planet with some kind
of scanning Ray this move has the
unintended side effect of juicing bee
back to life this chain of events poses
some other questions about how life for
a Transformer actually works we know
that every cybertronian has a spark
powered in part by Energon we call it a
spark
it contains our life force and our
memories